The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So here's
where we were.
So we were talking about
this example of b to s gamma
and a heavy to light current.
In terms of this chi
field, our current
was chi, which is going
to have some label,
in a heavy quark field.
And we did the one
with diagrams in SET.
We saw that after we take
into account also the 0 bin
contribution that it
breaks up as follows.
There's a piece
that I've underlined
in orange that matches
exactly with the IR of QCD.
There's a piece
that I underlined
in blue which is the
ultraviolet divergences
in the effective theory.
And so what we do
with that is we
add a counter-term
for the operators
and the effective theory to
cancel these divergences.
And then there's
whatever is left over
after doing that,
which is this pink.
And the difference
of the analog pink
in the full theory and this
pink will give you the matching.
So when I say
"matching," this is
part of what goes
into that matching.
So what I want to spend
today's lecture on
is really discussing
renormalization
in the effective theory
and summing logarithms
in the effective theory.
It's kind of interesting
and different than things
we've encountered before,
because we see even
at one loop order,
we have 1 over
epsilon squared divergence.
And that wasn't something
that we encountered before.
And so we have to see
how that plays out.
But just at the
simplistic level,
let's just say or
record for the record
that we could write
the following.
There was a Wilson
coefficient of this operator.
And we can divide it into
renormalize Wilson coefficient
in a counterterm.
And then we just think
that this counterterm
is canceling that divergence.
And so the counterterm
we need is the following.
So with this minus sign
canceling that minus sign,
you get plus.
And so the counterterm
for the operator therefore
should have a minus
and just all--
exactly these terms.
Because of kinematics
in this problem,
this omega, which is a delta
function in this operator,
is equal to actually mb.
And I'll go through why that
is a little later today.
So take it for granted for now.
It comes about just
simply from kinematics.
But I'm going to sometimes
write the mb as omega
because that reminds you that it
was this label in the colinear
field.
So this is the type of
counterterm we have.
It's got this 1 over
epsilon squared.
It's got this log, so it
looks kind of different.
And the notation
here is that we have
a coefficient that's
inside an integral, where
this thing meant that.
So basically what I'm saying
when I say omega is equal to mb
is that this delta function
becomes omega minus mb.
We'll come back to that.
So if we have a counterterm like
that, then we can do running.
So we'll come back
to this example.
Let me first make a
few general comments,
and then we'll come back and
see where this z leads us.
So in general, you're going
to have this structure--
some integral, some Wilson
coefficients that depend
on some omegas--
could be more than one of
them-- and then some operator
that has some delta functions in
it that pick out those omegas.
And because of that
integral, in general,
you have to be careful, because
that integral could also play
a role in the renormalization.
So that delta function
is picking out
the total momentum of
the product of the quark
field times the Wilson line.
And in our example, it's
fixed by external kinematics.
So I'll come back
to this and show you
that not in every example is
it fixed by external kinematics
in a minute.
But our example is special
because the integral actually
doesn't play an important role.
So there's in some sense
two parts of this statement.
There is the fact
that it's external,
and then there's the fact
that it's fixed to something.
So let me first deal with the
issue of it being external.
And what that means is it
does not involve loop momenta.
You see, when we
did the calculation,
we were basically
doing a calculation,
not worrying so much about
this delta function that was
sitting inside our operator.
We ignored it.
We didn't write it
down in our diagrams.
Technically, we
should have written
that delta function, this
delta function, down, too,
and included it in
our calculation.
But actually that's OK because
that delta function just comes
outside the loop integrals.
That's what I want to show you.
So it does not
involve loop momenta.
So in all the
diagrams we consider,
that's trivial, except for
one non-trivial example.
And that non-trivial
example is the example
where we had a colinear
vertex-type diagram like this.
So we called the
external momentum here p.
This was p plus k.
And if I let this guy go this
way, we can call it minus k.
You see, the Wilson coefficient
sits here at the vertex.
And it acts on the
colinear fields
that come out of that vertex.
But it gives some of the
momentum of those colinear
fields.
So we get this guy, and
then we get this guy.
And so we just kept
the external guy.
So from this notation, the
same thing as saying this delta
function.
We can see that it only
depends on the external p,
on the n bar dot k.
And that's because of the
structure of this operator.
So that won't always be true.
It could be the case that the
Wilson-- in a more complicated
example, that the
Wilson coefficient
could depend on the k.
And then that would
have some implications
for renormalization.
And we will treat an example of
that sort in the near future.
The second thing to ask
is, what does it fix to?
So if we put a little
more into our diagram,
let's put the photon in.
This is a b quark.
This is a strange quark b
to s gamma, for example.
Then the kinematics of the
external lines there is we
have mbv coming in for the
b quark, p of the photon,
and p of the external
strange quark.
And the photon is light-like.
p gamma squared is 0.
And in the setup
here, we can just
think of it as e
gamma times n bar,
because p is colinear to the
n direction, and it's going--
we have the photon
going this way.
And it's back to back
with a jet that's
described by the
colinear n direction,
just as the beam
goes on decaying
to a photon in a
back-to-back jet.
And so if you dot into
this equation n bar,
since n bar dot v is 1 in
conventional coordinates,
we just get that mb
is 0 plus n bar dot p.
And that's the statement
that omega was just mb.
So when we were doing our
loop calculations last time,
we kept writing mb.
We could have been more
careful and written--
well, we couldn't have been more
careful, because kinematics was
demanding that this was true.
But just in order to track what
the Wilson coefficients can
depend on, really what
they can depend on
is these labels of
these colinear fields.
And so I'm going to start
writing omega for that reason
because that's the more
generic thing that happens.
Even if we're not
in a situation where
it's fixed to be
some mass, we'll
be able to get
dependence on the values
of these parameters of omega.
So any questions about that?
All right, so this Wilson
coefficient just comes out,
and we didn't have to worry
about this delta function.
So how do we calculate
the anomalous dimension?
It's the usual story.
So mu d by dbu of the
bare coefficient is 0.
That implies a
renormalization group equation
for the ms bar coefficient.
And it's got this familiar form,
where the gamma is products
of z's and z inverses--
just this.
So this is an
all-orders formula.
If we plug in our
one loop result
here, then on the left, if we
worked order by order in alpha,
on the left-hand
side, we can just
take the 1 in the
zc universe here.
And the zc, when we
take b by d by d mu,
there's mu in the alpha s,
and there's mu in this log.
And we're going to have to
differentiate both of those.
So let me write it out.
So the minus sign
canceled the minus sign.
The zc inverse is just 1.
And then I have b db dbu over
the rest of this stuff, which
includes both the alpha
and the log mu over w.
These are the type of
contributions we get,
where these guys here are
coming from using the fact that
mu d by d mu of alpha when
you're in d dimensions is minus
2 epsilon alpha plus--
order alpha squared term's
related to the beta function,
which we can drop here.
And then this guy comes
from the explicit--
differentiating the
explicit log mu over w.
The divergent terms
cancel, and we're
left with a finite
anomalous dimension.
And it's got two
types of terms in it.
So the type of
anomalous dimensions
that we're used to are like this
guy, here-- this 5 times cf.
That would be like a
standard anomalous dimension
for an operator.
In this case, we
have this extra piece
that has this log of mu over w.
And this guy is what's called
cusp anomalous dimension,
the guy that multiplies the log.
So with that language,
you could call this guy
the regular anomalous dimension.
Now, if you're going to
do renormalization group
evolution, you're
going to sum logs.
You could think that you're
starting at some hard scale
like w. w is mb.
That's the hard scale.
And then you want to run
down to some small-scale mu.
When you run down,
if you take mu small,
this term is larger
than this term.
So actually, this
term here gives you
the leading-- what are called
the leading logs in this case.
And this term here is
actually only needed
for next leading log.
Because this term here
grows when you go down,
and that term doesn't,
this term here
is actually giving
you the leading logs.
So I'll come back and
talk a little bit more
about leading log versus
next-to-leading log.
And also, I'll explain to you
what this word "cusp" in this--
where's the cusp, since
we haven't seen it yet?
I'll come back and explain
where that is in a minute.
For now, let's just take the
leading log anomalous dimension
and see just to solve the
anomalous dimension equation.
So we'll just take
the leading long term
and not worry about
the other term,
so just taking the cusp term.
So plugging that back
into our equation for c,
we have this differential
equation, which we can also
write as d log c by d log mu.
And that's an equation
that we can basically
just integrate since there's
no c on the right-hand side.
It's a homogeneous equation.
We can integrate it with
some boundary condition.
So we could specify
the boundary condition
at an arbitrary scale.
Let me, for simplicity, use the
following tree-level boundary
condition.
So at tree level, the
Wilson coefficient was 1.
That we have to pick
some scale where
we make that statement true.
And for convenience, I'm just
going to take that scale to bw.
That makes things
a little simpler.
In general, you could make
this any hard scale, ie,
any scale mu of order w.
So you could call
it something mu 0
and consider the renormalization
group from that scale.
But for convenience, I'm just
taking that mu 0 to be w here.
So we take that down
[INAUDIBLE] It's
actually useful to
look at what would
happen if we didn't
have a running
coupling on the right-hand side.
So say we were doing QED, and we
didn't have any massless light
fermions, so there
was no running.
Then this coupling would just
be alpha, and it wouldn't run.
And then you'd just
integrate this log,
and you'd get a double log.
You integrate one log by d
log, you get log squared.
For each coupling,
you get log squared.
This is the double log
series that I promised you--
the Sudakov double
logarithms that
were going to come out of the
renormalization group of SET.
So QED with alpha fixed--
I'm going to take cf to be 1.
When you take the exponential
of what I just said,
then this is your result
for the Wilson coefficient.
And this is what's known
as a Sudakov exponential.
The leading log
Wilson coefficient
is the sum of these
alpha times double log.
So if I expanded this out,
I'd have an infinite series,
where for each pair of
logarithms, I get one coupling.
And that's the Sudakov
double logarithms.
So if we expand out
the exponential,
that's what we would get.
So really, I should make my
line go under the whole thing.
So why did we get
something like this?
So physically the reason that
we got this Sudakov exponential
or Sudakov form factor
is related to the fact
that the whole theory
that we've developed
put restrictions on radiation.
So there was
kinematic restrictions
put on the radiation by the
whole setup that we had.
We had this jet, and
it was colonnaded.
And the radiation was forced
to go inside that jet.
In the effective theory, we're
seeing the Sudakov exponential
come out of UV renormalization.
The usual picture
for it is that you're
thinking about IR divergences.
And you're thinking about
the real radiation, not
the virtual radiation.
But as you may be familiar with
what the effective theory does,
is if you have an IR divergence
in full QCD or full QED,
then what the
effective theory does
is it takes the scale
corresponding to--
so the IR divergences
are logarithms.
And they're logarithms of
something over something.
And we've done in
the effective theory
is we've introduced a scale mu.
We've introduced--
effectively, we've
taken the part of that
logarithm that was UV
and taken it to infinity.
And in this standard
way, we've introduced
a scale mu that splits things
between Wilson coefficients
and operators.
So there's this
factorization scale
that's splitting
the hard physics
from-- which is part of the
logarithm that we're capturing.
It's separating the hard physics
from the infrared physics.
And here, we're just
looking at the hard physics.
And we can see the Sudakov.
We could also look
at the real radiation
and see the Sudakov by studying
real radiation diagrams.
But in some sense,
this is easier,
because this is just coming
out of a renormalization group
equation.
So the usual way
of doing it would
be to just look at
in the full theory,
and you'd see Sudakov logarithms
from ratios of two things
that you were thinking of as IR.
Because the hard scale,
which is mbw here,
would also be an IR scale
from the point of view of QCD.
But here, it's become part
of the Wilson coefficient.
And now it can be treated by
the renormalization group.
So QCD is not really
any more complicated.
We just have to deal with
the running coupling.
We've done that before.
Let me remind you how it
works because it's slightly
more involved in this case.
So for the leading logs, we
just need the beta 0 term.
And we can switch
variables from d log to d
alpha in this equation, here.
And so then we have to integrate
this thing with respect
to d alpha.
And so what we can do
is we can take this log,
and we can also write the log
as an integral over alpha.
Alpha in this equation
is some w variable.
And so then just integrating
both sides of this equation
here, I can write
it out like that.
So the log became this thing.
And then one of these factors--
there was a minus sign.
But then when I use
this formula twice,
the minus sign goes away, and
I get two of those factors.
This is the other measure here
from the explicit d log mu.
So we could underline things--
half of this guy,
all of that guy, d
log mu, other half of
this guy and that guy.
And then there's this
explicit alpha cf
over pi, which I've written
as cf over pi out front,
and this alpha here.
So we do that integral.
We do this integral.
Well, all the
intervals are trivial.
We do this integral, and then
we get integration variable
at fixed quantity.
And then we can do
this other integral.
We get a solution.
So I'll show you what
the answer looks like.
It's, again, an exponential,
because we're solving for a log
c.
I'll write it like this.
So we're familiar that
renormalization group
equations, when you
have a running coupling,
can give you ratios of alphas.
We saw that when we were
running for fermion operators.
Here, it's just a more
complicated function,
but it's again a
function of that ratio.
And this extra structure
is coming about just
from the running coupling.
So the only difference
between this and QED Sudakov
is the running coupling.
So if we were to take this
now, and we were to expand z,
we were, say, to expand
about alpha of w,
then we would get logs
of mu over w, right?
And so what you should
think that this z dependence
encodes--
is an infinite series
in this exponential.
And so the structure of
that infinite series,
if I was to expand, would be
alpha squared u over w alpha
squared log cubed u
over w, et cetera.
So in the exponent, a
running of the coupling
is only giving you one
log for each alpha.
So the series that I'm
solving in the exponent
by taking into account
the running coupling
is a series of this form,
where I go down by one alpha
and down by one log.
So from the structure of what
we've been talking about here,
it should become clear that
the right thing to talk about,
if you want to do
counting, is log c,
because the anomalous dimension
equation was simple for log c.
It was mu d by mu or
d by d log mu of log c
is equal to something.
That something on the right-hand
side is an expansion in alpha.
And we could include
higher-order terms
in that expansion, but it would
always be of that structure.
So to talk about what
terms we're summing,
we can write the following
schematic equation
for different orders.
So if we have alpha
s to the k log
to the k plus 1, which is
this series I've just denoted,
we'll call that leading log.
And if we add some
higher-order term,
like alpha s to
the k log to the k,
then that would be
next-to-leading log.
And if we had more
alphas than logs,
then we call that
next-to-next-to leading log.
And the structure of the
anomalous dimension equation
always guarantees that if
you solve it for this log,
that this is what the
higher-order terms would
give you.
So you should think of it
that really, log counting
is kind of like normal log
counting, except for two
caveats in this theory.
You're doing it in
the exponential.
That's what taking the log did.
And you start out with one
extra log, one more log
than you're used to.
But after that,
it's kind of normal,
because I'm summing
here alpha times log,
and I just increment for
each alpha an extra log.
And that's all the
running coupling effects.
When I go to next-to-leading
log, of course,
we write in coupling effects,
too, and other things
that are causing the series.
But it's down from
this one because it
doesn't have that enhanced log.
And then this one is down
again because it's, again,
one less log.
So this is the kind
of terms that you
could sum by having
higher-order corrections
in the anomalous dimensions.
And for example, this
cusp anomalous dimension
is known at three loop orders.
So certainly, next-to-next-to
leading log is well within
the realm of things
that people talk about.
So let's ask that question.
What coefficients, if we
were to carry out this one
new calculation, and we
were to do higher loops,
what coefficients do
we need to compute?
So remember the story when we
were summing single log series
was we would do
tree-level matching
one loop anomalous dimension.
Then we'd do one loop matching,
two loop anomalous dimension.
What's the analog
of that story here?
Let's make a little table.
So what information do
we need at tree level?
What information do
we need at one loop,
two loops, three loops?
So for a leading
log, what we did is
we put in tree-level matching.
And at one loop, we
only actually took
the information that came
from the coefficient of the 1
over epsilon squared, which is
the cusp anomalous dimension.
[INAUDIBLE] here.
If you go to one
higher order, it
turns out that this is the
story to get this series.
We would need the two-loop cusp
anomalous dimension, the one
loop non-cusp, and still
the tree-level matching.
So this next-to-leading
log coefficient, this 5cf,
that's this 1 over epsilon.
In our example,
this was the 5cf.
And only when you get to
next-to-next-to-leading log,
then the matching is one loop.
We have the two-loop
regular anomalous dimension,
and then the 1 over
epsilon squared
cusp anomalous dimension
from three loop.
So it's kind of like
it's the usual story,
but we have an
enhanced-- because
of the double logarithms, we
have an enhanced thing that we
can talk about here,
where we're not
talking about the regular
anomalous dimension,
but this cusp
anomalous dimension.
So this is the
information that you would
need to go to higher orders.
And this cusp
anomalous dimension
is actually a universal thing.
So given that it's been
calculated, you can use it.
And you don't have to
recalculate it every time.
These pieces you have
to recalculate-- these 1
over epsilons, in general.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Can you
comment on the seemingly
arbitrariness of the
boundary condition you chose?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if I hadn't
chose that boundary condition--
sure.
Let me write something.
So the way that you could
think about the rg is
as follows-- that you have c.
And really what the rg is
doing is determining some u.
It allows you to run c from
some point to some other point,
like that.
So in this formula, mu
0 in some scale that's
of order omega or w-- it
doesn't have to be equal to w.
It could be 2w, 1/2w.
And the way that you're
thinking about this equation
is you're going
to do perturbation
theory for this thing.
And then in that perturbation
theory, you'll have alpha,
and you'll have log
squared of mu 0 over w.
But as long as you're
saying mu 0's of order w,
those aren't large logs.
And this thing here
in this formulation
would have the double log
series of alpha log squared
of mu over mu0.
But then mu0's of order w.
And mu you can
take much smaller,
and that's the large logs.
So for simplicity, I
just took mu0 equal to w.
Everything I've
said, I could repeat,
and this story would really
be the same if I just
used an arbitrary mu0.
And the reason you actually
want to use an arbitrary
mu0 in general is that you
want to do scale variation
to think about uncertainties.
And so the mu0 dependence,
just like in our--
when we were talking about
electroweak operators
and electric Hamiltonian,
the mu0 dependence
cancels between
these things here.
But that calculation is in order
by order an alpha cancellation.
There's no large logs associated
with that cancellation.
And so what it
allows you to do is
if you've truncated this
to some fixed order,
and you've worked to some
fixed order over there,
then you can probe how
much uncertainty you
have by varying the mu0.
This mu here will get tied up
with the mu in the operator.
So we can talk more about
where that mu goes later on.
But at the level of this
formula, it is-- in general,
it's the case that you would
do it with an arbitrary mu0,
and then only fix
mu0 at the end.
And you'd even vary mu0 to get
an idea of how much uncertainty
you have in your leading log
calculation, because varying
mu0 would probe the next
term in the series, here.
STUDENT: So when you say
tree-level matching, you mean--
PROFESSOR: I mean this c.
STUDENT: --equal to 1.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I mean this guy, here.
Right.
STUDENT: Right.
And if you want to go
to nnll, you'd take 1--
PROFESSOR: Then you'd have this.
That wouldn't have this term.
Yeah.
All right, any other questions?
OK, so what is this
cusp that we've
been saying the words for?
I'll answer a couple of
questions that have come up.
Where's the cusp?
So if we look back at our
operator, we had this operator.
And we could make a field
redefinition, if you remember,
and put the ultrasoft
effects into a Wilson line.
Now for this heavy quark
here, remember what that--
the theory for
that was with hqet.
So the field theory for this
heavy quark was an iv dot dhv.
And if we actually make a
similar field redefinition
to the one we talked
about to get this y,
but on the heavy
quark field, then we
can actually, in
terms of this guy
here, get a free
Lagrangian as well.
So actually, all the effects
from ultra soft gluons
in this operator can be
encoded in Wilson lines.
So let me do that.
So that just says
that actually, when
we talked about static
sources, static sources
could also be encoded
as Wilson lines
by a kind of
similar manipulation
to what we did when
we talked about SET.
So if we look at the
ultrasoft sector here,
we have a Wilson line
that actually has a path.
So there's a Wilson
line that comes
from minus infinity along
v to whatever position
we put our operator at.
Let's take it to be 0.
And then we have
a yn dagger which
is extending out to plus
infinity from 0, like that.
And the cusp is this
fact that there's
a kink in this Wilson line.
It's not a smooth path.
It actually has a sharp angle.
And that's the cusp.
So there's actually a general
renormalization theory
for renormalizing
Wilson lines with cusps.
So this is something
that at some point
in the history of QCD, people
tried to reformulate QCD
in terms of Wilson
lines, entirely
in terms of Wilson lines.
Then they realized that
they could have these cusps
in the Wilson lines.
And the renormalization
of that theory
became much more complicated
than the renormalization
of the QCD action
because they couldn't
prove that in general, these
cusps wouldn't come out
of the dynamics.
And then people dropped it.
But along the way,
anyway, they formulated
a general renormalization
theory of cusps in Wilson lines.
And whenever you have
a cusp like this,
you end up having, in
our language, this log,
single log, in the
anomalous dimension.
So if one of the lines here
is light-like, and one of them
is, because n squared was 0,
then the anomalous dimension
for this cusp will have a single
log like our log of mu over w.
So that actually holds
not only to one loop,
as we talked about, but
actually to all orders
in perturbation theory.
If we'd gone to higher orders
in perturbation theory,
then what would happen is that
the coefficient of that log
would get corrected.
But there'd still be only one
log in our anomalous dimension.
That's also something that you
can argue from SET directly.
But originally, it falls
from this general theory
of the renormalization
of cusps of Wilson lines.
So if you were thinking
about our calculation,
you may remember actually that
we got 1 over epsilon squared.
It's from the
ultrasoft diagrams.
And that's in some sense
what we've just talked about,
because these are the
ultrasoft diagrams,
and they have 1 over
epsilon squareds.
There was also 1 over epsilon
squareds from the colinear
diagrams, right?
So if you like, this piece
here also in some sense
has kind of a cusp.
And in this case, it's not--
it's actually what
we're doing is
we're taking a Wilson line
along the n bar direction, which
is our wn.
And then we're attaching
it to a quark field.
So this is a full
cn quark field.
It's not a Wilson line.
So you can think of it as
just ending on a quark field.
But even just ending
on a quark field,
the quark field
also has dynamics.
It's not as simple as
Wilson line dynamics,
but it has dynamics.
And we have interactions
between these.
And this is also kind of a cusp.
Although it's not a
simple Wilson line cusp,
it's also kind of a cusp.
So even the colinear graphs
with the Wilson lines
ended on quarks also produced
these q over epsilon squareds
and have this kind of structure.
And they actually have similar--
very similar relations to the
cusps in regular Wilson lines.
So that was one question--
what was this cusp?
Another question that
came up was this fact
that the w got fixed.
And so we could
ask the question,
in general, when
will that happen?
So when will the w's
that are showing up
in our Wilson coefficients be
fixed by external kinematics?
And actually, that's going to
happen in the following case.
We can actually state when it
will happen quite generally.
So imagine that we had an
effective theory SET that had
multiple colinear directions.
So then we could
build operators out
of all those different
colinear fields.
And we would do it with our
building blocks, which are
chi n or curley bn for each n.
And if our operator only
involves one building block
for each direction,
then it's going
to be the case that the value
of those labels or those omegas
are always going to be fixed
by external kinematics.
So let me just write
down another example.
Imagine we had something
like an LHC process,
where we had two gluons coming
in and two quarks going out.
But we'll think about
this as protons colliding,
coming in from two
different directions.
Let's call them n2 and n3--
and then going to two jets
transverse to the axis
by a large amount.
So there are also two
different directions,
which I can call n1 and n4.
So this process of glu-glu
goes to qq bar, which
is really pp goes to dijets.
As long as those dijets are
well-separated from the b
maxes, which is the case we're
interested in, then we have
this situation, where we
have four different n's.
And so what kind of operator
would you write down for that?
Well, you have
dw1, dw2, dw3, dw4.
You'd have a Wilson coefficient
that could depend on four
different w's.
And you'd then write
down some operator
out of building blocks, n1w1.
I'm not going to worry
about all the indices,
but I'll worry
about some of them.
That would look like that.
So I just put down some operator
that's got the right structure.
It's got two quarks, two gluons.
I make the gluons
these b [INAUDIBLE]..
I've chosen to contract them.
Each of them has a
different direction.
This is in n1.
And each of them also gets a
corresponding large momentum.
And the Wilson coefficient can
depend on those large momenta.
So this would be
the operator that
would describe that process.
But again, if you think
about the renormalization,
then if you think about the
renormalization for a minute,
the colinear
diagrams aren't going
to involve contractions
between this guy
and any of these other
guys because these guys are
totally independent.
They're a different Lagrangian.
So the contractions are,
again, just like the kind
of calculation that we did.
The colinear diagrams are just
coming from this thing alone,
and they don't care
about that stuff.
So it's actually
the same calculation
that we already did
for b to s gamma
if I wanted to do the
colinear diagrams here.
And then I would have
to do the colinear
diagrams for each of these guys,
but it's kind of independent.
And again, the w1 is external
for that calculation.
So the anomalous
dimension would just--
it would be outside it.
It wouldn't
involve-- it wouldn't
appear and get thrown into
some loop integral momentum.
And so if you think about
what can fix these w's, it's
really only external
information.
So what are the
momentum fractions
of the incoming
quarks from the PDFs?
What are the energies
of the outgoing jets?
That's the type of information
that, even in this case,
would fix the w's.
So if we were to calculate
the Wilson coefficient
for this operator and do
its renormalization group,
there would again--
it would again be
of a product form.
There's no convolution,
just a product
for this Wilson coefficient.
So when could that not be true?
It could not be true
if, for example, we
had a chi bar and a chi that
were in the same direction.
So if we're in a situation
where all the objects are
different directions,
that's what happens.
And it's pretty simple.
But let's also do an
example when is it not true.
It's always good to
have a counterexample.
And it would not be true if
we had an operator like this.
So here's an operator
with just two quark
building-block fields.
I gave them different labels,
because in general, the Wilson
coefficient could depend
on their large momenta.
But now, they're in
the same direction n,
so they belong to the
same colinear sector.
And in this operator here,
we would actually no longer
be in the case where this
thing would totally decouple
from the loop integrals.
So if we think about
inserting this operator,
then some of these guys here
will involve loop momenta.
Actually, it turns out that one
combination of the w's is still
fixed by external kinematics.
And so there's an overall--
think about the overall delta
function on this product.
That guy would be fixed.
And then some difference of
these w's would not be fixed.
That's the true story about
at least one combination
that involve the loop momenta.
And what does that lead to?
How does it complicate
what we've already said?
What that leads to is
that when we formulate
the anomalous
dimension equations,
they also involve integrals.
So for this guy here, for the
one momentum that's not fixed--
so in general, there's two.
And this is the one
that's not fixed.
We would get an equation
that looks like this.
Rather than the
simple product form,
there'd be an integral
on the right-hand side.
And indeed, actually, if
you do the renormalization
of this operator that I wrote
up there, just that simple quark
operator, you actually
reproduce a bunch
of classical evolution
equations that are of this form.
So even just the
simplest possible case
we can think of where
things are not fixed
gives us a bunch of
interesting results.
So for deep
inelastic scattering,
then what you're getting is
the Altarelli-Parisi equation
or DGLAP equation.
And the evolution
of the operator
would be the evolution of
the part-time distribution
function.
That's one thing that would be
encoded in the renormalization
of that equation.
There's other processes
that are actually--
some of which we may
talk about later on--
that are also encoded
in the same type
of operator, kind of a
different projection of it.
And one of them leads
to something called
the Brodsky-Lepage equation.
And then there's another
one that's showing up
in something called--
a process called deeply
virtual Compton scattering.
So the one that's most
familiar is the renormalization
of the PDF.
And you may remember that the
renormalization of the PDF
has this form of
having an integral.
That'll come out of
renormalization this operator.
And we'll do that case.
So in general, the structure
of the effective theory
is leading us to find
out what the structure
of the renormalization is.
And it can reproduce some
well-known, classic things,
but it comes out
actually pretty easy.
So I'm going to do
this case, but I'm
going to do this case
in complete-- with all
of the details filled in.
So first, I have to
convince you that
in deep inelastic scattering,
you actually get that operator.
And we'll see
precisely what kind
of matrix elements
of that operator
show up in deep
inelastic scattering, why
we get that operator.
And then once we're convinced
that we have that operator,
and we'll actually drive
a factorization theorem
that involves that operator.
Then we'll talk about
its renormalization group
evolution.
And I'll show you that
it has this form that I'm
writing here.
So probably for the rest of
today's lecture, certainly
for the rest of today's lecture,
we won't get to the running.
We'll do that next time.
But we'll at least get
to the point, I think,
where you'll see why that
operator is showing up in DIS.
So let's do DIS.
So I'm only going to talk
in DIS about factorization,
and then the renormalization
group evolution.
So no phenomenology, nothing
like that-- we'll just
talk about these two concepts.
So DIS is electron-proton to
electron anything, so just
kinematics.
Think about a virtual
photon exchange.
Proton comes in.
I'll say that the
proton's momentum is
a capital P. Gets blown apart.
Call the stuff that's
blown apart Px.
And so Px is the sum
of all the particles,
all the final-state hadrons.
Q squared of the
virtual photon--
so this is q.
Little q squared is
minus capital Q squared.
And this thing is much
bigger than on QCD.
mu arc in x is capital Q squared
divided by this dot product.
And you can talk about
Px, which is the Px mu.
And by momentum
conservation, that's
the proton momentum, plus
whatever momentum came in
from the leptons q.
So Px squared--
if you square it,
well, this guy is giving you
mass of the protons squared.
And then there's a dot-- a cross
term, and this guy squared.
And if you put those
things together like this,
so this is an exact equation.
Px squared is that.
And so there's actually
different regions of DIS,
and we're only going to
talk about one of them.
I have to enumerate what
I'm talking about carefully.
And I can do that by looking
at Px squared or this factor
1 minus x over x, which
I'll call 1 over x minus 1.
If this thing is
of order q squared,
then that means that this
thing you're counting
is of quarter 1.
And in that case, it's what's
called the inclusive operator
product expansion.
So this is the case that
most books would deal with.
And that's the one we'll
deal with, actually,
where effectively, we're not
putting restrictions on x.
We're just saying it's
generic, and it's not
approaching any endpoints.
There's also a situation
where the Px gets smaller.
And then this thing is close to
an endpoint, lambda QCD over q.
And that's called
the endpoint region.
And people talk about that.
Usually when people
say x goes to 1,
this is what they mean--
that the 1 minus x minus 1
is of that size
on the QCD over q.
There's even a third region,
where the Px squared becomes
hadronic lambda QCD squared.
And that's like
here, two powers.
So taking that factor
to be really small.
And that's the resonance region.
And that's the case where
the final state x is just
another proton or an
excited state of a proton.
So that's where elastic
scattering would be.
And that's an exclusive process.
It's not inclusive anymore.
So actually, all three of these
cases can be done with SET.
And the way that it works
is different in each case.
And the case that
we'll do is just
the first one, which is kind
of a classic one, and also
the simplest one.
So our Px squared is
going to be of ordered
q squared for our analysis.
We also need some
partonic variables.
So the struck quark carries
some momentum fraction
from the proton.
This is the familiar language.
And for our analysis, what
we're going to do is just
take m bar dot
little p of the quark
to be something times n bar
dot big P of the proton.
So the fraction is
this c variable,
and it's the ratio of the
quark momentum to the proton.
But we'll do it in a very
particular component,
and we'll see why that's
the right thing to do.
And if we have our
picture here of the quark
kinematics, then this
P is the incoming P.
And the outgoing P would
be P prime, let's say.
So I could think about an
analog of this equation, where
I square P prime.
And if you do that, it's kind
of similar to the hadronic case.
The only difference is
that the c shows up.
And, of course, there's
no mass of the proton.
So P prime squared
would be that.
So we'll see how this
variable c shows up.
Now, one thing that we
have to decide about
is frames of reference,
because remember,
when we were talking about
degrees of freedom in SET,
we had picked a frame
to do that discussion.
And it was almost always a
center of mass frame so far
in our discussions, or the rest
frame of the initial state.
And here, we're going to use a
slightly different frame, which
is the most convenient frame
for deep elastic scattering.
It's called a Breit frame.
So we're going to do our
analysis in this frame.
So what defines this frame?
This frame is defined
by taking q mu
to just have a z component.
Remember, it's space-like,
so it has to be somewhere
in the space-like column.
And we can choose
it such that it's
entirely in the z
component, and nowhere else.
And that's the Breit frame.
If we want to
write that in terms
of our classic decomposition
of nnn bar, is we
can write it as a
difference divided by 2.
And that's giving
the z component.
So in this frame
what's happening
is that your initial
state proton is coming
in with a very large momentum.
And then it's being--
you're killing that momentum
and then spitting it back out
in a different direction.
So you're spitting back out
stuff in a different direction.
So the initial state proton is
coming in with a large momentum
in some direction.
So if you work out the
kinematics given that for what
the proton would be,
the proton's momentum
would be in the following form.
So it's got a large--
this is large,
and this is small.
And if you have
a large component
in some light-like direction,
that means it's colinear.
So you could actually
write it as--
using momentum conservation,
you could write it like this.
And it has a colinear scaling.
So what we have in
the deep inelastic
scattering in the Breit frame
is that the incoming proton
is a linear proton.
And if we look at
Px, and we just--
again, I'm not going
through the details of this.
But if we just decompose Px
in terms of these coordinates,
then we get this.
And so as long as this factor
1 minus x over x is of order 1,
you see that there's
a large component in n
and a large component in n bar.
And that means it's hard.
So what would happen in
these other cases here
is that you would
change that, right?
It would no longer be hard.
And that's why these
cases here are different.
But as long as we're in this
first case, this is hard.
And we can say that we have
colinear modes and hard modes.
And then we just want to
write down an effective theory
for those two things.
You could also do
an analysis of DIS
in the rest frame of the proton.
That's another case.
And actually, the final
result that you would get
would be the same.
That's what we'll
get from this frame.
But this frame is
actually a little easier.
So we're really talking about
hard colinear factorization
in some sense.
Colinear describes the
low-energy degree of freedom,
which is the proton.
And hard describes the
off-shell final state
and the hard fluctuations.
And really, what we want to do
in DIS in this classic case is
just separate hard and
colinear fluctuations,
at least in this frame.
So we can do that for
the cross-section.
So let me remind you something
about the cross-section in DIS.
So just using nothing
more than the fact
that we're treating the leptons
order by order in the photon,
we can work the first-order in
the electromagnetic coupling.
And then we can
write down a formula
like this, where we split it
into electronic and hadronic
tensor.
And the hadronic
tensor can be written
as the imaginary part of some T,
where T is the following thing.
So this doesn't use
anything about--
we haven't used any sort of
perturbation theory or anything
to write this-- what
I'm telling you-- down.
We just worked all
orders, and basically used
the optical theorem.
So T is the time order
product of the two curves.
Let me call this z.
Actually, I don't
know if that's--
before you start
doing anything in QCD,
that's how you could write this.
And these are the
electromagnetic currents
for a quark.
STUDENT: But wouldn't you
write it over that, though?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Thanks, yeah,
because x was something else.
Don't want to use x.
All right, so for
this T mu nu, we
can also use
current conservation
and decompose it
into two pieces.
So this is a classic
thing that we do in DIS.
And nothing about
the fact that we're
using the effective theory
really changes during this.
What you're after--
the effective theory
is calculating these T's,
which would be coefficients.
And this part is all standard
stuff for any analysis of DIS.
So if you're not familiar with
it, or you don't remember it,
it's actually not
that important.
But using the current
conservation of T,
the fact that when I
dot a q into the T,
you should get 0, because you're
dotting a q into the current.
The current is conserved.
It's electromagnetic current.
That tells you the possible
structure of this thing
and that there's two
general terms if I'm
doing a spin sum, which I am.
There's the sum
over spin up there.
If we weren't summing over
spin, if we were picking out
particular spins of the
proton, then the formula
here could be a little
more complicated.
So this satisfies
all the symmetries.
And in general, what
you know is that you
want the imaginary part of
forward scattering graphs.
So pictorially, it's sometimes
useful to draw something.
So here's a forward
scattering graph.
And the thing that's
different that we have--
know now-- and the information
that we're going to use
is that we're assigning
the external guys
to be colinear and the
intermediate guy to be hard.
So we want to integrate
out the pink guy, as usual.
The guy we want to integrate
out is always pink.
And we want to keep
these colinear guys.
And so the operators in
the effective theory--
we can already intuit what
they should look like.
They're just going to involve--
I have a current
with two photons
hanging out of it, and
then colinear quarks.
Those guys-- those are
the external lines there.
And there's actually
also an analogous thing
with colinear gluons.
And that's what
the type of-- so I
could have an operator
at higher orders, where
the external states
here were gluons.
And that's what the operators
of the effective theory
are going to look like.
Just contract that
pink line to a point,
and that's what they look like.
So given that we know
what they look like,
we just have to write
down the lowest dimension
operators of that form.
And the lowest dimension
operators of that form
are exactly the
operator that I told
you was going to be
the one that comes in.
So we can enumerate
the lowest dimension,
which where dimension here
is counted as lambdas, right?
So it's the lowest order in the
power counting operators, so
not the lowest order
in mass dimension.
Let me write out a few things.
Yeah, I already switched
to this notation.
Yeah.
So the type of operator
we'd have that's
order lambda squared--
this guy's order lambda.
This guy's order lambda.
That's lambda squared.
And the most general thing
we can think of is this.
The reason why I wrote this
out rather than writing it
as a chi field is I
wanted to emphasize
that there's a flavor index.
So i is up quarks, down quarks,
strange quirks, et cetera.
And then we could
also have gluons,
and gluons are similar except
in terms of our curly v field.
And it is actually just a
contraction of two curly v's,
and then traced over.
And then there's some
Wilson coefficient here
which is also just the Wilson
coefficient for the gluon.
So this is, again,
order lambda squared.
The b perp field is
So we just write down the
lowest dimension operators
that have this form.
And that's going to
be the right answer--
the lowest order in lambda.
So it turns out actually
that in this case,
our lambda counting is exactly
the corresponding twist
expansion.
I'm not going to--
STUDENT: All j's correspond
to the operators that go
into the T1's and T2's?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So now what's the
index j exactly?
There's a T1 and a T2.
And the T1 and the
T2, although they
have the same kind of quark
and gluon field structure,
they get different coefficients,
and that's what the j is.
So when we think about doing a
similar kind of decomposition,
the effective theory, we
can write it as follows.
So as an 01 and an 02.
And I think if I'm getting
my mass detentions right,
it looks like this.
So there's a piece that
multiplies a spin structure
that's this g perp mu nu.
That's transverse to Q.
And there's a piece
that multiplies
this guy, which is also
transverse to Q in the Breit
frame.
So that's the kind
of decomposition
we would do in the
effective theory.
There'd be two different
types of operators
we could think about.
But the only thing
that actually tracks
that-- because of
the spin relations,
the only thing that tracks
that is the Wilson coefficient.
And so that will differ in
these two different cases.
So this guy here
is going to be--
this will give the quark PDFs.
And this Wilson
coefficient will then
be the thing that you convolute
with the quark PDF in DIS.
And then likewise, this guy is
going to give the gluon PDF.
So let's do the quark--
we'll do the quark
contribution in detail.
The gluon contribution
is not really any harder.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm not
going to think about it
in perturbation theory.
I'm just going to think about
it to all orders in perturbation
theory.
And really what that
means is I'm not
going to think about this c as
expanded in perturbation theory
or think about any of the
diagrams here as expanded
in perturbation theory.
I'm just going to see,
if I manipulate things,
what does it lead
to, using things
like momentum conservation
and stuff like that?
So let me write--
in order to do that,
let me write it
slightly differently than I
just did, which I apologize for.
But I'm going to--
I want the arguments of the c,
just for a later convenience,
instead of being w1
and w1 to be w plus
and w-- minus the sum of
the w's and the difference
of the w's, but
everything else the same.
It's convenient
to just talk about
the sum and the difference
rather than the individuals.
So what's the parton
distribution function?
Let me convince you
that it's actually
related to this operator.
If you were in coordinate space,
the coordinate space for us
was z.
We're just leaving x
for something else.
Then you could define the
parton distribution function
as a proton matrix
element of quark fields
with a Wilson line between them.
So they're on the light
cone, and we have a formula
like that.
And also, one can
convince oneself
that if you want to write
down for the antiquarks what
the part-time
distribution function is,
it's the same formula
as the quark formula,
just with an overall minus sign.
And z goes to minus z.
So that's an operator definition
of the part-time distribution
function.
You can also define it by
moments of the operator.
That's the way that, for
example, Peskin does it.
But if you put all the
information in those moments
back into a single operator,
then it becomes this thing.
And if we Fourier
transform this,
then it becomes the operator
that we have up there.
So there's something special
about the matrix element
we're taking here.
And that is that this
matrix element is forward.
It has the same
kinematics for the--
so this is a colinear proton,
but we have the same momentum
here and here.
In the in state
and the out state,
you have the same momentum.
And that leads to one
kinematic restriction
on what I'm about to write.
So what that imposes is that
w1 should be equal to w2.
So there's a delta
function of w minus
that comes from the momentum
conservation or the restriction
that it's a forward
matrix element.
But the sum of the two--
with my sign conventions,
it's w minus.
The sum of the two
is unconstrained.
Well, it's bounded,
but unconstrained.
So we can write the
unconstrained part
as this interval of c parameter.
The bounding just
comes from the fact
that the quark can't
carry more momentum
than the overall
momentum of the proton.
So that's why it's bounded.
It can't carry negative
momentum, and it can't carry--
negative physical
momentum, it can't carry,
and it can't carry less
momentum in the proton.
That's where the
limits come from.
And then there's two pieces.
The w plus could
either be positive,
or it could be negative.
If it's positive,
remember, positive
labels-- that was our quarks.
So this is the quark piece.
And these are the antiquarks.
They come with negative labels.
Remember that we talked
about that earlier.
And so both the f and the f bar
are hiding inside this formula.
So there is a
simplification that there's
this delta function here.
And so basically what
we're talking about then--
you can think of just
doing the integral
over that delta function.
So then you're talking about
effectively an operator
where you don't worry about
putting a label on this one.
You have only one
delta function left,
which I can denote by
putting a label on this one.
And this operator is
actually exactly the operator
that gives you the PDF.
This operator is like
a number operator
for quarks, where
you're thinking
about momentum, a number
operator with momentum omega.
And if you want to
think about there being
some kind of field for a
parton, this is about as close
as you can get.
So this quark field
dressed by Wilson line
is kind of like a parton
in the parton model.
All right, so next time, we'll
take this, put it together
with this formula
here, with the c,
and just see where it leads us.
And it will lead us
directly to a factorization
theorem for deep
inelastic scattering
involving parton
distribution functions
and some hard perturbatively
calculable thing, which
is actually a cross-section
in the parton model.
And then we'll talk about
renormalization [INAUDIBLE]..
You can already see that we're
getting the operator that I
promised you-- that
DIS is described
by this, by a linear operator
with two different quark
fields, and particular
labeling of the momenta.
Any questions?